when you're flying on a plane
this is going to be a good bit but i've
already burnt it now um wait because the
punch line is and you're on a plane no
no but it's like a masseuse when you're
with a masseuse the masseuse is that
much hotter because she's massaging you
yes i understand that phenomenon okay
when you're on a plane movies are better
because you're on a plane i agree and
there's nothing you're a captive and by
the way things are funny the only movie
i saw that still stunk on a plane well i
knew i didn't even like listen to it i
just watched him like going this is
horrible was he pray love that was
horrible
couldn't be saved
by a player just visually because you
know you just visually you go i don't
even hear this oh my god yeah i'm now
drunk on
on spring water
i think part of your delight is that you
drink like a toddler like you there's
like
like a
toddler what are you saying
what the hell is going on
that was so shocking i'm just saying i
would love to chase you with a wet towel
just like crack at you while you're
trying to eat a pudding pop
i don't eat pudding pops anymore i don't
have sugar no more pudding pops no more
pudding pops i love pudding pops done
do they they even stop making them the
real see it's like they like they change
the recipes for a ho hos i guarantee
pudding pops aren't the same all right
that's a new level of subtlety i know
the subtlety of junk food that's how
much of an addict i was really i am i'm
still see i approach it like an
alcoholic i'm not an alcoholic but i um
i've turned it this way sure um they
made sure don't turn it yeah do you know
the suits we could we can you know the
spring water people known to be militant
they'll go right at us
those hippies it's actually quite
delicious i like it a lot it's fresh
it's light young people enjoy it